Hey Team, it’s Charlie and Fox just announced
that the Deadpool Movie is back on.
They have a date, this right here 2/12/2016,
they have a director and they have an actor.
What fine actor have they chosen?
You guessed it, Ryan Reynolds is still attached
as is director Tim Miller.
The two were the ones originally working on
the film back when Fox first put it into development
back in 2011.
Here are the Top 8 awesome things that we
can all be excited about:
Number 8 - The leaked test footage is a better
trailer than a real trailer ever could be.
And it came at the right time.
Deadpool is being released in the winter,
but it’s a comic book movie.
Awareness and engagement for those types of
movies peaks during the summer.
Particularly around Comic Con.
We can thank all the Hall H exclusives and
big reveals studios hold for that weekend.
It just trains people to attach themselves
to their computers and cell phones waiting
for updates.
Low and behold, some unofficial but very authentic
seeming Deadpool test footage starts getting
passed around.
Fox takes it down, guaranteeing it’s authenticity
and heightening demand.
Over the comic con weekend the footage gets
taken down and reuploaded several times and
Rhett Reese, the writer of the current Deadpool
movie script launches a twitter campaign.
Retweet if you would buy a ticket to a deadpool
movie.
Comic Book Creators like Bendis, Fraction
and Rob Liefeld as well as other big celebrities
throw their support in via twitter and facebook.
And everything goes quiet near the end of
August.
Probably not though, because Fox executives
probably saw what was happening early on and
decided to move forward.
It just took this long for them to announce
the movie because contracts needed to be signed.
If you ever wonder why Marvel doesn’t announce
stuff more often, it’s because actors, writers
and directors haven’t signed contracts yet.
Movie studios only make official announcements
when everyone involved is legally bound to
complete the movie.
Number 7 - Even though the test footage was
largely digital effects, the movie will mostly
be live action.
There are a lot of ways digital effects can
help a Deadpool story, mostly talking severed
heads, but the current movie culture is returning
to the familiarity of practical effects.
That means building things in real life instead
of in the computer.
You may have noticed JJ Abrams trolling Zack
Snyder with this Millenium Falcon reveal.
Underneath you can see the old Christopher
Nolan tumbler attached in a very empire strikes
back way.
Abrams, rather than build everything on a
green screen chose to build most of the large
sets, aliens and vehicles.
A very wise choice in my opinion.
Marvel still uses a lot of digital effects
for their movies, but a lot of times the choice
of CG versus practical effects just comes
down to budget and time.
We know the movie is scheduled for release
February 2016 which gives them till next summer
to shoot the film.
For quick turnover movies like Avengers and
Deadpool they can get a movie out within 8
months of shooting the actors.
Again, that window, also very dependent on
Budget.
Bigger Budgets means you can hire more post
production people to get your movie out faster.
Given Ryan Reynolds involvement and it being
an X-Men Franchise movie I’d guess their
budget will be between 60 and 80 million dollars.
Maybe more if FOX thinks it’s a guaranteed
hit.
Number 6 - The Director Tim Miller isn’t
just the original director attached to the
project.
He’s the guy at Blur Studios who leaked
the test footage before comic con this year.
Arguably the first in a series of events that
led Fox to pulling the movie out of mothballs.
Blur Studios are the people Fox hired back
in 2011 to develop the project.
They’re primarily known as a visual effects
studio.
Miller himself has been very lucky.
Had the public response not been so great,
FOX could have sued him into oblivion for
leaking the Deadpool footage.
Fox is owned by Rupert Murdoch, he’s every
bit as litigious as Mr Burns on the Simpsons.
Clearly if he was willing to risk being thrown
in a deep dark hole, he must really be passionate
about the movie, which is key and makes me
optimistic that he’ll do a good job.
There’s a lot more involved in making a
good movie than just the director.
But he’s the one guy everyone working on
the movie goes to for answers.
That’s why a lot of movie directors get
labeled as glorified traffic cops.
That’s kind of pejorative though, so if
you know any directors in real life and you
call them that, they’ll probably punch you
in the face.
Number 5 - Ryan Reynolds is still attached
to star
He’s not currently under contract but still
remains committed to the project.
Shooting dates and making him official just
requires working out the schedule.
Right now Reynolds has two movies he’s committed
to in addition to Deadpool, all three of them
are scheduled for release in 2016, which means
next year, they’ll all be filming.
One of those movies is Croods 2, which will
only require voice-over work and isn’t half
as demanding on his time as a live action
movie with a lot of other actors on screen
at the same time.
So it’s totally possible for them to shoot
the movie with him.
If they ran into big problems, what they might
do is shoot any footage of him without the
mask on if they needed to.
And then for the remainder of the film.
Just use a body double and have him provide
the dialogue when his schedule permitted.
It’s a lot easier to shoot a movie if you
don’t actually need your a-list actor on
set all the time.
And because Wade Wilson pretty much wears
the mask full time, if they wanted.
I feel like the fandom wouldn’t care if
he never took the mask off completely.
Fox’s renewed interest in the project probably
has a lot to do with Reynolds.
So the chances this movie goes into production
increase exponentially the minute they get
him under contract.
Number 4 - They already have a finished script
from the original writer Rhett Reese
No word on whether this is the script that
they’ll shoot with or if they’ll try to
re-write it.
But the mere fact they have a finished script
is a huge bonus and add to that, the test
footage everyone saw.
Was based on parts of Reese’s Script.
So if you liked the way the test footage played,
you’ll probably enjoy the rest of that story.
The rest of it is said to include a ton of
equally crazy action sequences.
And yes, it was written as a very hard R movie.
Mostly for violence and gore.
But also lots of foul mouthed wisecracking.
Number 3 - The Script also features Several
Mutants from the X-Men Universe
Just to name a few there’s, Wyre, Ajax,
Sluggo, Garrison Kane and Daniel Cudmore’s
Colossus.
And Deadpool specific characters like Vanessa
Carlysle and Blind AI.
Supposedly there’s more but I haven’t
seen the script so this is all just based
on names that have been released.
Fox of course owns X-Men, so using mutants
is easy.
I like the implication that Deadpool will
get to mow down some superheroes and supervillains.
The character is a mercenary at his core,
so as long as a hit shows up on someone it
doesn’t matter if they’re good or bad.
No word on who the presumed Big Bad would
be but there’s Sabretooth, Taskmaster, Venom
and Bullseye and a bunch more.
Deadpool has had a beef with at least 50 characters
and not all of them were villains .
A lot of the characters are owned by other
studios.
So Fox might bend canon a little and use some
other notable big bad from inside the X-Men
Franchise.
Or it will be some crazy mind-fuck and deadpool
will end up ordering a hit on himself.
I don’t think Fox would let the story get
that crazy.
That would feel more like an episode of Doctor
Who.
Number 2 - The Official Synopsis For The Character
Huge Man, armed to the teeth with twin Katanas
and Set Matching Desert Eagle Pistols.
His Sarcastic Wit and ever-running mouth are
nearly as deadly as his fighting prowess.
Has a tendency to break the 4th wall and talk
to the audience.
Boyishly handsome in his youth but is presently
extremely disfigured with scars over face
and body.
Let’s be honest, Wolverine is the most popular
character Fox owns, but Deadpool just from
reading that, is the most fun.
And you guys will like this last one.
The Number 1 awesome thing about the Deadpool
Movie is that because it can exist in the
canon of the X-Men films.
Deadpool will know that he was a character
in a movie and can make jokes about said movie.
I think we can all admit that Wolverine Origins
was a little silly with all the screaming
at the sky and the one-liners.
But imagine deadpool spending half a movie
making fun of it and making fun of himself
in the movie.
His ability to break the fourth wall can at
times be both amazing and incredibly confusing.
Which is part of why it’s so much fun.
So big question for you guys, do you think
Deadpool should be able to make jokes about
Wolverine Origins in the movie and who do
you want the villain to be?
In related news, I’m working on a Constantine
and Game of Thrones video for later today.
Be sure to subscribe to join the team.
I’m doing episode videos for all the comic
book shows this year and it’s going to be
amazing.
I’ve seen all the new shows and yes, some
are better than others, but they’re all
a lot of fun.
Right now click here to get that constantine
video, i’ll add the annotation as soon as
I post it and click here to learn about Agents
Of SHIELD Season 2 which starts next week.
Thanks for watching, we’ll all reconvene
later today for Constantine whatnot.
High Fives!